he's the anchor of CNN's Cuomo primetime
and host of Sirius XM's let's get after
it Chris Cuomo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there was a time when you brought on an
anchorman and they would not get a
standing ovation an anchorman are kind
of having a moment did you read that
story they're big popular on none on
talk shows and stuff yeah my Sarah
pissed isn't talking to me about it a
lot recently you have a therapist I was
here with Howard Stern we'll have a
whole team I don't she's the only one
left in the control group okay but you
know CNN which is where you're at yes I
mean you started at Fox I didn't know
that I was reading him but I did what
was that like did Roger Ailes ever grab
your ass I know but apparently I was one
of the only ones that he did did start
there is my first job you fit in with
the they must have known your pedigree
no I left I left for a reason you know
the funny thing is Roger was one of the
only people who would hire me because he
took a chance on whether or not I would
be able to be fair you know at the time
you couldn't come from a political
family and have any hope in journalism
that you'd have to be an analyst you
know or go into politics itself and I
didn't want to do that so he gave me an
opportunity to try out lots of different
parts of reporting he really knew a lot
about interviewing in particular but the
idea of telling a story but eventually I
had to leave because I couldn't tell
stories the way he was already there are
people mad at you because you said some
nice things sort of about Roger Ailes
and this is something you and I both
faced with because we platform people
Chris in other words we give people who
we don't agree with a chance to speak
and there's a lot of liberals who hate
that because you should only talk
amongst the people who already agree
with you I mean they hate you because
you are friends with Kellyanne Conway
and have her run I wish that were the
only thing I feel hey I'm so surprised
when anyone is nice to me at any time
you know including my kids cuz
everybody's got an opinion
now they usually just not watch now I
wish they didn't watch well it's
interesting because CNN used to be the
neutral station I mean there was MSNBC
on the left and you had Fox News on the
right I mean we all knew that sometimes
I would
Fox News just to see what they're saying
I couldn't take too much of it I knew it
MSNBC was but seeing I was like okay
these guys are trying to play it right
down the middle
now you're getting sued by the president
how do you play it down the middle I
guess it's the question when the
president is so far to one side well
look I think what has changed is the
president and how he has decided to
conduct his office there is nothing new
there's nothing non neutral about facts
you know if you want to talk about
what's going on and test arguments that
is what it is it's not left or right
either you're telling the truth or
you're not if your argument makes sense
or it doesn't I think what has changed
is how this president is what we never
had before was someone who would say no
it's not that I disagree with you it's
that you're a bad person bill for asking
me that question you're bad but
shouldn't like you called you and it's
fake what I said about me fake scum he
said that about his own people I know he
said that about people in his party he
didn't say it about me said much worse
human scum but Wow and then the press
secretary this is what's new so usually
the press secretary comes in and says no
you heard scum I heard thumb which means
they're just one part of the hand now
she comes in and says yeah that's how it
is if there's been against this
president that's how we should speak
about you that's the biggest problem I
think we all well and also I mean at the
CNN
the trust factor in CNN's gone way down
from something like 64 percent 20 years
ago to like 48 percent what is that
about you saying it's just me no I
I was nervous about this I know I know
why here's what I think has happened if
we are honest with ourselves people have
been skeptical about institutions in the
media for a long time you can get a
sense of bias in the media that it's
only telling you certain stories a
certain way and I think very often that
criticism is well-founded however I will
tell you this this president is playing
on every weakness in our social fabric
I believe the book that will be written
about him that will be most dispositive
of what he meant is the luckiest man in
the history of the game because he lies
a lot and people suspect that they all
lie he you know says that he's going to
do something but it doesn't happen that
way they believe it's the industry
standard in politics he does things with
Ukraine they believe what must happen
all the time
he says the media is fake people have
been suspicious of that so he's playing
to people's prejudices as a demagogue
does but I'll tell you this bill I've
never had so many people say I support
what you are doing as is happening right
now but you get a lot of hate as you
said I do
those are only my four cousins that
clapped right I mean you know you hell
hey - by the way not I don't like what
you said come to your house find your
kids on social media right talk to your
kids in a restaurant know I love you
years old and say things that you should
only say man to man that's new for me
yeah no I know you had that dust-up when
you with the Fredo thing oh you heard I
heard about that and you know I feel bad
field I mean look believe me I get some
of this too but I don't have a family so
I'm too worried about kids thing Christ
but it must be hard I can't I can't
imagine what that's like but but the
Fredo thing I just got it would bother
me about that is that liberals have this
reputation for make everything identity
politics and Fredo yep sorry it's just
not a thing it's just not a slur it's
not an Italian slur it means dumb
brother which you're not but you have a
brother who's the governor of New York
that's where that came from
I'd like to see you call him that came
from is I've dealt with this it's not
about ethnicity I think the context
matters that is not my experience though
they talk about they call me Italian
name yes ever since he came into office
they started identifying me by ethnicity
mobster this Godfather that I say it as
an extension if your father had it when
he was the governor York there were
there was that was one of the
scuttlebutt things they would say about
him like Oh Mario Cuomo he's somehow in
with the mob because he's Italian that's
a slur on the Italians Fredo just means
dumb brother okay we can agree to
disagree well I'll tell you what's
interesting about I guess this is social
progress that you can now have an
opinion about what an Italian can find
offensive
okay goodbye
usually when we shake hands you're gone
just in fact well thank you I mean of
course well it's interesting because a
lot of times people white men aren't
allowed to have an opinion about
anything it you know political
correctness has a great set of goals and
how we get there has been very uneven
and I think it's a concern for us as a
society because now you have a president
that once again is playing to people's
questions about political correctness
and not in the way that you do with this
razor sharp scalpel on when it makes
sense and when it doesn't which is part
of your genius and that finish your
thought Chris but that's not what he
does
no what he does is his plays on all the
prejudices that make political
correctness necessary and you know we
have to be careful that you don't wind
up punishing the people that you need to
help protect your cause and I think
we're still fine okay so I watched you
on the lgbtq Town Hall yes CNN had this
to me says a lot about the Democrats
here are the Democrats doing a town hall
just for the LGBT community
yes liberal people supporting this
liberal principle and they were
interrupted by protesters who I guess
thought they weren't going far enough
beto
and Pete who I believe has some
credentials in the LGBT community
we're both interrupted by people
screaming you know trans lives matter
no one was disputing this what did you
make of that here's what I made of it
cuz I was there I got to see it first of
all what I loved seeing was not just the
candidates cuz they know they're being
measured for how they deal with
situations like that but I thought that
Anderson and Don Lemon had happened for
Anderson Cooper and Don Lemon of both
their segments I loved that they
respected the protest because the
transgender community specifically feels
so targeted I got where they were a but
not beautiful but we're there to help
yes but what they saw was a chance to
get their message out and
really believe that they're being preyed
upon they're being hunted and it was an
opportunity for them to get a national
audience to see that they're scared and
they need help and I respect that which
is what the Democrats were doing okay
listen I'm happy to go after it and call
things out where I don't like it okay my
show is all about but you know I don't
protect okay so the tooth three-fourths
of the squad came out for Bernie Sanders
yes yes yes they did I just I laugh at
that because I don't know how that squad
thing actually happened like I don't I
don't know why we're calling a bunch of
freshmen some kind of entity of
influence in a system they just got into
because they do have a lot of influence
they have a lot of social media
influential cachet the media loves to
talk about them but I think you have to
put points on the board if you're going
to earn your office get things done for
your constituents not just for your own
profile I love you
snatch if that were his name that was so
Italian I take no offense no you should
but is that the squad coming out for
Bernie first thing I thought was that's
good for Elizabeth Warren because
because it makes him to the left of her
and she needs to move to the middle and
what always happens not unusual in
politics you know this I'm sure all of
you do also is that primary takes you to
a pole a polar position within your
party and then you try to fight your way
back to the center I think what's going
on with the Democratic Party is a little
bit more extreme than we've seen in the
past we had a poll not too long ago that
said if the person running against this
president identifies as socialist or can
be identified reasonably as socialist
right they lose by six points so I think
labels matter in politics they do I
think the senator Sanders has a tough
time in defining socialists as a good
thing to a capitalist society that
doesn't like the idea of that kind of
district distribution of assets in
general even in his own party I don't
think it really goes I think they got a
tough task Chris Cuomo thank you very
much
[Applause]
you